[Applaudissements]
bonsoir c'est Pascal selem pour MTV il
est 8h55 dans 5 minutes le match OM -
Paris Saint-Germain et comme j'ai pas de
télé comme d'habitude je suis allé chez
les gens on est à Marseille on est où là
à Marseille à Marseille je suis avec
Kamel et puis on va taper chez les gens
on y va
c'est bon c'est bon je suis beau ça fait
rien comme ça il y a quelqu'un
bonsoir c'est Pascal selem pour MTV on
peut venir voir le match chez vous on va
regarder le match
mais vous regardez le match
bonsoir on peut se mettre là allez allez
il va commencer c'est gentil
c'est gentil
je crois que tu es en train de tomber
amoureux de moi
oh non pas lécher pas lécher c'est à
vous le chien madame vous savez quoi on
va le tuer
mais moi au moins j'enlève mes
chaussures
je sais que les odeurs pour les femmes
enceintes c'est très très fort il y a
pas d'odeur vous êtes sûr quand même
[Rires]
le grand-père le petit-fils la fille et
le beau-fils
alors pas de gros mots alors le premier
qui dit un gros mot c'est une grande
claque
c'est quoi la spécialité culinaire de
Marseille
[Musique]
je vous donne 10 minutes moi
vous avez de la boîte
vous allez manger nous on a pas du tout
mangé
[Musique]
alors une un jus d'orange à la bière
parce qu'on a pas le droit à l'alcool et
moi un jus d'anis s'il vous plaît OK
et où est-ce qu'il casse son argent ton
papa
à côté de l'ordinateur
dis-moi où dis-moi
voilà en tout cas c'est la première fois
qu'on vient voir un match avec un couple
échangiste
tu vas me crier comme ça dans les
oreilles pendant toute la soirée
je sais que c'est important mais on est
en train de trinquer Sébastien tu
trinques avec nous allez allez
Yang à l'OM c'est rempli de chinois au
stade
c'est pas les Chinois c'est les Chinois
oui alors je tiens à vous dire que je
vous invite tous à mon spectacle qui
commencera le 9 novembre jusqu'au 21
novembre au quai du rire à Marseille mon
premier one man show qui s'appelle Léo
de la caméra donc vous serez mes invités
puisque vous avez eu la gentillesse de
nous inviter ce soir avec Kamel pour
regarder le match
c'est 80 euros vous pouvez régler tout
de suite
vous êtes sûr que vous voulez pas vous
mettre sur le canapé ça me dérange de
voir une femme enceinte sur une chaise
pourrie
tu t'es pas beaucoup trompé parce que
regarde la maison
je rigole vous avez le droit de taper
c'est quoi comme comme race ce chien
c'est quoi c'est un turbo diesel
c'est le petit qui pète depuis tout à
l'heure
c'est le chien
bêtement comme ça pendant toute la
soirée
une semaine
excusez-moi vous avez allumé le
chauffage ou quoi
l'amitié c'est ça vous recevez les gens
chez vous c'est minimum quoi déjà vous
nous recevez chez vous il y a pas la
clim on dit rien au bout d'un moment on
a chaud il veut prendre une douche c'est
gentil
la serviette
je vous laisse la serviette c'est
laquelle
mille la serviette
[Musique]
bon il y a pas d'eau chaude
ça fait du bien
[Musique]
si c'est comme ça nous on s'en va on a
été bien gentil de d'accepter de venir
chez vous
dans les pâtes
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci infiniment au plaisir allez au
revoir merci bien Kamel allez viens
allez au revoir merci
[Musique]